الوضع في شمال سوريا تجاوز وصفه بالكارثي
الى ما هو اعمق من ذلك سكانه علقوا بين
الموت تحت الانقاض والتجمد في ظل البرد
القارس بينما يفتقرون للحدود الدنيا من
البنيه التحتيه والصحيه والمدنيه التي
تسعفهم في مواجهه هذا الدمار الوقت الذي
تلا الكارثه كان الاكثر اهميه فجاءت كارثه
فوق كارثتين الاولى الحرب التي افقدتهم
ابسط مقومات الحياه طوال 12 عاما والثانيه
زلزال مباغت اتى على ما تبقى ليحصد الاف
الارواح والحصيله النهائيه مخباه تحت ركام
وفوقها 11 مليون متضرر في محافظات حلب
وادلب واللاذقيه الاكثر تاثرا بالزلزال
بجانب حماه وطرطوس حلب الواقعه على بعد
155 كيلو مترا من مركز
القهرمان مرعش التركيه اكثر من 400 الف
فيها باته في العراء
شاهدينا هذه مدينه الاتارب وهذه بلده
جنديرس التي سجلت وحدها اكثر من الف قتيل
تعرض 70 في المئه من مبانيها للدمار
والمشاهد استنسخت ايضا في ادلب ارمناز
وسلقين حارم وعزمرين اختصار تحولت المدن
المنكوبه الى اراض خوت من كل شيء عدا
الركام والموت والعوس والكارثه الثالثه هل
من مغيث
اليوم الخامس بعد الزلزال اول قافله
مساعدات تدخل من معبر باب الهوى من الجنوب
التركي خلت من الخيام والغذاء او قافله
الثانيه بعد اليوم السابع حملت مواد ايواء
مجدوله وليست اغاثيه للزلزال اما النجده
الحقيقيه فجاءت في اليوم التاسع وذلك بعد
فتح معبر باب السلامه الموصد منذ 2020
جراء ضغط الروسي على مجلس الامن الدولي
ادى الى تعديل اليه ايصال المساعدات عبر
الحدود مسؤولون في منظمه الصحه العالميه
زاروا حلب المدمره بعد ايام من الزلزال
وطلبوا من رئيس النظام السوري فتح المزيد
من المعابر الحدوديه
لضمان توصيل المساعدات
وقبل
[موسيقى]
ماساه لا تفاقم قسوه الماساه في سوريا
ضحاياها فقراء في مناطق سيطره نظام وايضا
فقراء في مناطق كانت تقصفها طائراته شمال
البلاد وحتى بعد الزلزال ادلب واجزاء من
شمال حلب بلا سلطه افقر المناطق واكثرها
تضررا شهدت انهيار اكثر من الاف المباني
اما مناطق سيطره النظام طرطوس حلب وحمى
اللاذقيه دمر الزلزال المباني فيها
بالمئات واين يظهر الفارق يظهر الفارق في
الانقاذ قوات تستنفر تحت سيطره النظام
بمساعده الجيش الروسي واياد تمزقها
الانقاض والركام خارج اسواره على المقلب
الضعيف المهترئ الخوض البيضاء راسه حربه
عمليات الانقاذ شكى الضعف مواردها البشريه
في تغطيه عمليات البحث
استغاث عناصرها في ظل الدمار الحاصل على
خط القرى والمدن المنكوبه الظروف المناخيه
ايضا كبحت الامل 2500 الف عنصر عفوا عنصر
دفاع مدني ويكافحون الامطار والثلوج في
سباقا مع الزمن للوصول الى احياء بين
الاموات